[Music]
james is in portland maine hi james
welcome to the ramsey show
thanks dave i'm calling to get your
opinion on whether to quit my 200 000 a
year remote finance manager job in order
to homeschool my two daughters and work
toward changing my career
i'm 39 and i'm married to a doctor who
makes 300 000 a year
we are debt free other than our 380 000
mortgage on a home worth approximately
650 000
we have a six-month emergency fund three
hundred and fifty thousand in 401k
and 50 000 in college funds so far wow
how old are you guys
i'm 39 my wife is 34. phenomenal
pretty incredible situation you've
gotten yourself into well done gives you
a lot of choices doesn't it
yeah another wrinkle i wanted to share
is that my wife's specialty has very odd
hours on evenings and weekends so given
my eight to five schedule we often end
up like ships passing the night so
another feature of this decision
potential decision would be that i'd get
to spend a significant more you know
significantly more time with her you're
eight to five remote
i'm eight to five remote so i work with
people throughout the country um and to
have meetings with them and things like
that i
i work those hours yeah
in finance
yes so finance is in i am a back end
finance uh person for a consulting firm
oh
okay so these are corporate meetings not
consumer meetings i got you okay yes yes
okay cool very cool what would the side
hustle be
uh well that's something i want to
develop i
have a background in you know kind of
creating some content and things like
that so i was i'm thinking that might be
something i want to do part time again
i don't i it would be like 15 20 hours a
week rather than
a significant amount of time because i
would want to focus on the homeschooling
okay
well number one
financially you can just quit
in homeschool right i mean you got 300
000 of your income
and you're just stay-at-home debt right
that's not a problem
uh financially mathematically you can do
that
um but math isn't given isn't what's
giving me a pause here
what's giving me a pause is you're going
from working full time
to not at all
and i think you have an uh
maybe
there's parts of this picture that
you've painted that are more beautiful
than they are
when you start doing it
the second thing that it gives me a
little bit of pause
is there's a part of this and
it says you have the ability to bring
200 000 to your family regardless of
what your wife works
or makes
to
manage that ability poorly
and just quote flip the switch and walk
away today
feels uh irresponsible
there's a part of me that wants to say
that
so i think that that ability to create
that much income that much value for
your family
the transition from that should be
managed very carefully and deliberately
to minimize how much of your earning
potential is
lost um
and because i'm not positive that 15
hours is actually the actual limit
limiting factor for instance if you were
doing some kind of financial analysis
that you could do
uh when the kids are asleep
or at times that your wife is at work
and the kids are asleep or whatever
where we're not ships passing in the
night where you're not uh where you work
around the homeschool thing you might
still get in 40 hours pretty easily if
you just had a more flexible environment
as an example so i don't know ken yeah
i've got a couple questions james what's
driving this and there's no wrong answer
but what's driving it is it the kids
being homeschooled
is it you coming home to
take a break for a season and get the
benefit of being around the kids and the
wife i mean what's really driving this
the homeschooling is definitely part of
it i mean when we saw that they're
putting kindergartners on ipads we
really didn't like that idea so we moved
to a place that had quote unquote grade
schools
and then we saw that and
we were not thrilled with that the idea
we were how do you go back to books
after having an ipad it was my question
and so we were really concerned about
that so that was one of the main drivers
the ships testing tonight's another one
of them and the other is
i went and looked up what the top 10
career was at the time that i was great
you know when i was in college and i
chose finance
it isn't necessarily my passion either
so it's kind of i do feel a little bit
like i'm running away
from something
uh
to speak to what you were saying dave
but
at the same time i feel like given the
freedom that i do have should i be
running away towards something that i'd
like to do more the answer is well the
answer is unequivocally yes but what
dave is saying and i agree with dave
let's
let's not just bolt right away let's
think of a strategy you know the idea of
a bridge i just like using that analogy
what's the bridge to take me from where
i am to where i want to be and i think
you got three factors here two of the
three
uh by the way all legitimate and and i
just wanted to know what was behind this
because two of the three are family and
relational and because you've got the
financial wherewithal to do it
i i'm fine with it i don't have red
flags hearing those three answers but i
do have a red flag on do you really know
how you're gonna do as homeschool dad
because i think you'll have a more
satisfying
end to this story a more richness of
soul
if you find a way to create something
that you earn in the marketplace that's
different than what you're doing
it may or may not be finance related and
it but it certainly
doesn't necessarily have to be 15 hours
uh you there's lots of hours in the week
that um the people do lots of things
that are complete waste of time
and so i
i think you will like
your life better yourself better
if you are
somehow being a better steward of your
capacity
and it's not to say being a homeschool
dad is not a good steward of it that's
not what i'm saying i'm just saying
you're jumping from a high performance
situation
um completely out of the nest
and um
i just think you're gonna have more of a
shock more whiplash than you think it's
just you're just asking a couple guys
and we're just we're just talking by the
way we don't think there's anything
neither one of us think there's anything
wrong with your idea no uh or your
ability to do it you have the luxury i
just want you to think through it and go
is there can we slow this down just a
little bit
turn up the heat on
the tre what we're transitioning to not
from yes a little bit and i think you'll
get a better result yeah because with
the ships in the night thing isn't going
to be resolved either way this is his
wife's got a crazy schedule so if he
he's going to see more of her apparently
with this move but
there's other ways to do the
homeschooling there's other ways to do
that you don't have to be the homeschool
teacher
so i just i would ask you to do more
research look at every angle possible on
how do we accomplish the kids being in
the learning environment that you want
you doing something that you really
really enjoy and getting to spend more
time with the wife don't assume that
this is the only way to do it i think
that's really what we're driving at yeah
but what a wonderful place to be
fantastic hey you've got the heart for
it
um and
b the math in the household allows you
to do this and so absolutely on um
on the way you know it's the way to go
no question about it so yeah i just i
there's um
there's a stewardship thing for me on
everything that that overcoats my whole
life
and so i often look at that and go okay
i have this
ability and i'm supposed to i have this
potential i have this
bandwidth
and am i using that to its fullest
potential
or am i just letting it go dormant and
escaping and and i i have a tendency to
do the escape thing like everybody else
does i have to stop and think about it
but it's one of the things it's that
whole concept that keeps me working
i don't have to be here that's right
financially but i'm here because of i
have the bandwidth i have the ability to
reach a whole bunch of people still
and uh and so i need to do that
i need to do that i'm going to have a
best my best life because i did that's
right that's what i'm looking for hey
good question man love it thank you for
calling in real real brain teaser